Curb Your Enthusiasm tenth season people
must be asking it's been a phenomenal
success how long do you keep this going
you know you're at that stage where
people go how much longer it's still
great yeah
but they want to know and I always find
that question to be a little rude when
people say to me hey Conan how much more
you know you talking about exactly like
really oh really yeah how much long
you're gonna be a lawyer for yeah that's
not right yeah but I mean you ask the
question and I've pondered it you know
what I am kind of getting old
yeah I'm young old that's what I am
you mean as all people go you're young
as old people go I'm young but I've just
entered old but on the young side you
know that I made sure and I remember
like watching Buster Keaton when it got
old yeah not comparing myself to buster
Keaton's right example well I could tell
you roll because you're talking about
Buster Keaton and they don't know what
anyway you know when you got old showed
up in movies now in the 60s is from the
30s when people were like oh my god he's
now and I went oh you know you kind of
recoil yeah and you know I don't want
people I don't want to get to the point
where you know this recoil you know I
saw some pictures of myself last week in
a magazine and I went oh my god that's
in the what a horrible horrible face you
know right couldn't believe it yeah it's
funny you mention that because I have
the magazine that magazine is not just
any magazine it's GQ you were on the
cover this men was on the cover of GQ
magazine
HECO say Larry I love that you look like
they that you had no idea you were going
to be on the cover of a magazine
what's a magazine yeah you know see look
I see you wearing the same clothes now
that's ridiculous why is the same outfit
they wanted me to wear their clothes
yeah that's what GQ wants they want you
to wear Ralph Lauren suits ridiculous
I'm not gonna do that
you know I said I'll wear my own clothes
and they said okay right yeah I wouldn't
have done it close so you did GQ which
is like the magazine where you get to
wear all the great outfits and suits and
cool looks and you stuck with what you
would wear if you were going to subway
to get that really good parmesan
sandwich pretty much pretty much yeah I
think it was a wasted opportunity I
think we all would have loved to have
seen you in some really great oh really
I do and we took the liberty of seeing
what that would have looked like Larry
and some quick outfits let's take a look
at the first one right here and I think
that's
we have a next one right here and I
think this is you and then finally
there's this one and I think you're I
[Applause]
know if I live back then I think I would
have worn all that stuff gladly I like
that look yeah this is an actual photo
there's an actual photo from the shoot
oh you look horrified why would anybody
pick that out to put in a magazine they
clearly didn't like me I must have done
something - I don't I think you gave
them a lot of choices Larry I think you
gave them no choices I think you box
them into a corner you showed up with
this you said I'm here for five minutes
I don't do photos inside I think you
just an absolute delight chatting with
you we're done you want to do more what
the hell all right
all right I have a question yes quickly
do you have freckles still on your body
like when you're taking a shower do you
see practice no really not freckles they
all they all run away they mind is mine
I'm swear to God and II realized to be
true I wish I didn't yeah it's part of
the job people anyway yeah I still have
freckles all over my body but I don't
have them on my hands and face but you
don't mind him on your body cuz nobody
could see you yeah nobody's ever seen me
naked that's the saddest thing you've
ever said to me this is why we could
never be friends yeah we could never be
friends if I came to your house and just
knocked on the door and I knew you were
there would you answer the door and
invite me in if I if I knew was you
outside okay yeah I probably won't open
the door but sometimes you're expecting
somebody else all right
delight talking to you very excited to
say that Curb Your Enthusiasm season 10
premieres oh we have a clip I love that
this is a professional or show is yeah
producer Frank smiley he's been on the
show for 26 years is in the background
he just went
what what what an example of the of your
Encanto it is an example my god I am NOT
here to promote the show you let me show
it clip ready to go I I'm phoning it in
like you went to Harvard no way here's a
clip from Curb Your Enthusiasm sorry
again for the delay
I am diarrhea I want to come right back
in a little bit and check on you okay
having her head I'm pretty sure she said
have so she's in the throes of it
[Music]
[Applause]
premieres on HBO January Sunday night
Sunday I don't like the way I'm nobody
knows page January 19th you think people
are aware of dates they know Sunday this
Sunday in all of January 19th
[Applause]
we're never gonna be friends Larry David